- [Instructor] So we have
the graph of Y equals f of x
right over here and we want to figure out
three different limits and like always
pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
on your own before we do it together.
Alright now first let's
think about what's the limit
of f of x it's x approaches six.
So as x, I'm gonna do this
in a color you can see,
as x approaches six from both sides
well as we approach six
from the left hand side,
from values less than six,
it looks like our f of
x is approaching one
and as we approach x equals
six from the right hand side
it looks like our f of x is
once again approaching one
and in order for this limit to exist,
we need to be approaching the same value
from both the left and the right hand side
and so here at least graphically,
so you never are sure
with a graph but this is
a pretty good estimate, it looks
like we are approaching one
right over there, in a darker color.
Now let's do this next one.
The limit of f of x is x approaches four
so as we approach four
from the left hand side
what is going on?
Well as we approach four
from the left hand side
it looks like our function,
the value of our function
it looks like it is approaching three.
Remember you can have a
limit exist at an x value
where the function itself is not defined,
the function , if you said
after four, it's not defined
but it looks like when we
approach it from the left
when we approach x
equals four from the left
it looks like f is approaching three
and then we approach four from the right,
once again, it looks like our
function is approaching three
so here I would say, at
least from what we can tell
from the graph it looks like the limit
of f of x is x approaches four is three,
even though the function
itself is not defined yet.
Now let's think about the
limit as x approaches two.
So this is interesting the
function is defined there
f of two is two, let's
see when we approach
from the left hand side
it looks like our function
is approaching the value of two
but when we approach
from the right hand side,
when we approach x equals
two from the right hand side,
our function is getting
closer and closer to five
it's not quite getting
to five but as we go from
you know 2.1 2.01 2.001
it looks like our function
the value of our function's
getting closer and closer
to five and since we are
approaching two different values
from the left hand side
and the right hand side
as x approached two
from the left hand side
and the right hand side we
would say that this limit
does not exist so does not exist.
Which is interesting.
In this first case the
function is defined at six
and the limit is equal to
the value of the function
at x equals six, here the
function was not defined
at x equals four, but the limit does exist
here the function is defined
at f equals, x equals two
but the limit does not exist
as we approach x equals two
let's do another function
just to get more cases
of looking at graphical limits.
So here we have the graph
of Y is equal to g of x
and once again pause this
video and have a go at it
and see if you can figure
out these limits graphically.
So first we have the
limit as x approaches five
g of x so as we approach
five from the left hand side
it looks like we are
approaching this value
let me just draw a
straight Line that takes us
so it looks like we're
approaching this value
and as we approach five
from the right hand side
it also looks like we are
approaching that same value.
And so this value, just
eye balling it off of here
looks like it's about .4
so I'll say this limit
definitely exists just
when looking at a graph
it's not that precise
so I would say it's approximately 0.4
it might be 0.41 it might be 0.41456789
we don't know exactly
just looking at this graph
but it looks like a value
roughly around there.
Now let's think about the limit of g of x
as x approaches seven so
let's do the same exercise.
What happens as we approach from the left
from values less than
seven 6.9, 6.99, 6.999
well it looks like the
value of our function
is approaching two, it doesn't matter
that the actual function is
defined g of seven is five
but as we approach from the left,
as x goes 6.9, 6.99 and so on,
it looks like our value of our function
is approaching two, and as
we approach x equals seven
from the right hand side it
seems like the same thing
is happening it seems like
we are approaching two
and so I would say that this
is going to be equal to two
and so once again, the
function is defined there
and the limit exists
there but the g of seven
is different than the value
if the limit of g of x
as x approaches seven.
Now let's do one more.
What's the limit as x approaches one.
Well we'll do the same thing,
from the left hand side,
it looks like we're going
unbounded as x goes .9,
0.99, 0.999 and 0.9999
it looks like we're just going
unbounded towards infinity
and as we approach from
the right hand side
it looks like the same thing is happening
we're going unbounded to infinity.
So formally, sometimes
informally people will say
oh it's approaching infinity
or something like that
but if we wanna be formal
about what a limit means
in this context because it is unbounded
we would say that it does not exist.
Does not exist.